A very common theme in the Quran is
Allah's absolute control over
everything, even the choices of
individual souls to believe in him or
reject him. Now, this is a very
controversial point and there are
numerous Muslims who will argue with me
on this point and have been doing so in
the ongoing series on the Quran that
Hatun Tash and I are doing. The fact is
that they say it is not Allah's absolute
control over everything that decides
whether someone will believe in him or
reject him. That is up to the believer.
And so the question is do believers in
Islam
according to Islam have free will?
That's the question. Chapter 2:7 of the
Quran says, "Allah has sealed their
hearing and their hearts and over their
eyes there is a covering. They will
suffer an awful doom as we have already
heard about the doom quite a bit." Now,
Allah has sealed their hearing and their
hearts. A lot of Muslims will tell you
that that means that Allah only seals
the hearing in the hearts of people who
have already rejected him. The taps al
jal says of the unbelievers that Allah
does not remove blessings from them
until they exchange their good state for
disobedience. So it seems as if from
that that the disobedience comes first
and then Allah punishes them that the
sinners those who reject the law have
only themselves to blame. And there are
other passages that seem to support
that. For example, chapter 6:12,
say to whom does whatever is in the
heavens and the earth belong. Say to
Allah, he has prescribed mercy for
himself. Why he needs mercy is not
explained. So that he may bring you all
together to the day of resurrection
about which there is no doubt. Those who
ruin their own souls will not believe.
And so it seems clear the people who
reject the law are ruining their own
souls. It's not that he's doing it.
Chapter 9 verse 70 in the same way says,
"Hasn't the fame of those before them
reached them? The people of Noah, Admud,
the people of Abraham, the dwellers of
Midian, and the disasters, their
messengers came to them with proofs. So
Allah surely did not wrong them, but
they wronged themselves. So this seems
to make perfect sense, right? The
believer, the unbeliever sins and he is
punished. That's it. They wronged
themselves. Chapter 30:9. In the same
way, haven't they traveled in the land
and seen the fate of those who were
before them? They were stronger than
them in power and they dug the earth and
built upon it more than those have
built. Messengers of their own came to
them with clear proofs. Surely Allah did
not wrong them but they wronged
themselves.
Now other passages say that actually
it's Satan who leads believers astray.
And so of course a those things go
together. There's no real problem there.
A believer can choose to listen to Satan
and thus go go astray. And so you can
say he wronged himself by listening to
Satan. So Satan says in chapter 4 verse
119, "And surely I will lead them
astray. And surely I will arouse desires
in them and surely I will command them
and they will cut the cattle's ears and
surely I will command them and they will
change Allah's creation." Whoever
chooses Satan for a patron instead of
Allah is indeed a loser and his loss is
clear. And there are other passages in
the same vein. But still other passages
of the Quran as well as indications from
Islamic tradition state that no one
believes in Allah unless Allah wills it.
And also no one can disbelieve in Allah
except by his active will. Now we find
this in the same chapter 6 verse 25.
The same chapter that said that they
brought their trouble upon themselves.
It also says among them are some people
who listen to you but we have placed
veils upon their hearts
so that they may not understand
and in their ears a deafness. If they
saw every sign, they would not believe
in them to the point that when they come
to you to argue with you, the
unbelievers say, "This is nothing other
than fables of the men of old." So
notice the unbelievers who go to the
Muslims and say, "This is just fables of
the men of old, they're only doing it
because Allah placed a veil on their
hearts. Otherwise, they wouldn't."
Now, that's remarkable. But it is
repeated several times in the Quran
chapter 10 verse 100. It is not for any
soul to believe except by the permission
of Allah. He has set uncleanness upon
those who have no sense. So you see
people who are unclean, it is because
they do not have the permission of Allah
to believe. It's very clear. Chapter 16
verse 93 says, "If Allah had willed, he
could have made you one nation. But he
leads astray those whom he wills and
guides those whom he wills." And you
will indeed be asked about what you used
to do, which is kind of strange really
when you think about it. Why will they
be asked about what they used to do if
it's Allah who lead led them astray? If
Allah led them astray, then it's not
their fault what they used to do. It's a
loss, but nonetheless, he's going to ask
them about it. Chapter 24, verse 40. Or
a darkness on a vast abysmal sea. There
covers him a wave above which is a wave,
above which is a cloud, layer upon layer
of darkness. When he holds out his hand,
he can barely see it. And he for whom
Allah has not appointed light, for him
there is no light. I don't know what
could possibly be clearer than that, but
maybe it's chapter 32:13,
which says, "And if we had so willed, we
could have given every soul its
guidance. But the word from me
concerning evildoers took effect that I
will fill Gehenna with the jin and
mankind together." So, we could have
given every soul its guidance. You read
in the New Testament that God desires
all men to be saved and come to the
knowledge of the truth. This is a stark
contrast, an absolute contrast to that.
We could have given every soul its
guidance, but instead he says, "I will
fill gehenna with the jin and mankind
together." There are several other
verses in that vein, but they make it
clear that everything is in Allah's
hands, even the decision of the
individual to obey him or not. And even
when you encounter unbelievers who are
full of opposition to Islam, it's by the
will of Allah. And yet human beings for
no discernable reason will still be held
accountable for the things they have
done. Yet those who've rejected Allah
according to these passages of the Quran
do so because he made it possible for
them to do nothing else. Ibn Cathir the
great commentator on the Quran says
these ayat indicate that whomever Allah
has written to be miserable they shall
never find anyone to guide them to
happiness
and whomever Allah directs to
misguidance he shall never find anyone
to guide him so it's all up to Allah so
that would seem to contradict the
passages that state or suggest that it
is the believer who wrongs himself or
the rather the unbeliever the sinner I
should say who wrongs himself and not
Allah who wrongs him. It seems actually
very clear in these other passages of
the Quran that it is Allah who wrongs
him. So how are we to resolve this
contradiction? This has been something
that has been a preoccupation of Muslims
throughout history. And actually in
early Islamic history, a party known as
the Kadaria, a faction within the
Islamic community is said to have tried
to advance the idea of individual free
will. They actually said that the idea
that Allah controls everything even the
disbelief of the disbelievers was an
unworthy conception of Allah. So they
were saying we are giving you a higher
vision of Allah that Allah would not
lead people astray and send them into
hell just on his whim. He wouldn't do
that. He would be merciful as he always
says in 113 of 114 chapters of the
Quran. He would own not wrong the
disbelievers but they wrong themselves.
This is what the kadaria argued. But
their opponents battled them on the
basis of the Quranic passages that I
read just now and others like them that
say that no one can disbelieve in Allah
except by his active will that we could
have given everyone his guidance but
instead we will fill hell with gins and
men. And it was the opponents of the
kadaria who won. The kadaria were
declared heretics.
And so these Islamic apologists who are
appearing in the Quran study that Hatun
and I are doing, they're actually they
don't realize it, but they are heretics.
I suppose it's possible that they could
they might realize it and they're
deceivers, but it's more likely that
they are, as Hatun said in the segment
that we just videoed recently, that they
are longing for a God who is better than
the Allah in the Quran. They're looking
for a God who doesn't damn people and
torture them just for fun, but wants all
men to be saved and come to the
knowledge of the truth. And so they're
they're imposing that view on the Quran
so as to make it bearable to believe in.
But that's not a Quranic concept or at
least not I should say not an Islamic
concept. It's been declared heretical in
Islamic tradition. A 12th century Muslim
jurist, Iben Abi Yala, fulminated that
the Kadaria wrongly consider that they
hold in their grasp the ability to do
good and evil, avoid harm, and obtain
benefit, obey and disobey, and be guided
or misguided. They claim that human
beings retain full initiative without
any prior status within the will of
Allah for their acts nor even in his
knowledge of them. He said their
doctrine is similar and this was the
worst thing as far as this guy was
concerned. Their doctrine is similar to
that of the Zoroastrians and Christians.
It is the very root of heresy. And I'll
submit to you that's Iben Abby Yala was
absolutely right. That is the Christian
idea that God is good and does not d
desire the death of the sinner. And that
is one of the primary differences
between Islam and Christianity. Thank
you.